in the ongoing CBS News series I on
America we're taking a closer look at
some of the employees and families whose
lives were up ended by those massive
roundup of undocumented workers in
Mississippi last week federal agents
arrested about 680 workers at seven food
processing plants in six different
cities now one of the plants at the
center of the raids has a history of
troubling legal allegations CBS News
contributor Maria Elena Salinas is here
with more on this story so Maria Elena I
guess the first question is how are the
families doing well they're they're
doing okay they're difficult for them to
be dealing without having their loved
ones you know families whose loved ones
were arrested in the raids say they not
only relied on their family members
income but also they relied on their
help day to day life we spoke to one
family who doesn't know when or if their
father will come home Ingrid's son ty is
now the sole caretaker of nine children
six of her own including her
seven-year-old son who has autism
her husband Eddie Sorek who is the sole
provider for the family was arrested in
last week's raids along with her
sister-in-law it wasn't perfect but I
really did love him
of the 680 people detained around 300
were temporarily released but Sunday's
husband was undocumented was not one of
them every day
I need a look at my kids crying this
woman who asked us not to use her name
out of fear for retaliation works at
cook foods and witness raids
I wanted to alert others in the
community that ice was there so they
wouldn't come to work she says as we've
learned it's a workplace with a
troubling legal history more than 50
former and current workers at cook foods
filed a sexual harassment and labor
abuse lawsuit against the company in
2011 not even a career you were touched
by the supervisor and the supervisor
would tell you that if you complained
about it you would get fired
so you didn't complain the lawsuit was
settled last year for nearly four
million dollars although cook food said
these cases involved numerous contrived
and fabricated allegations of
mistreatment they were Pro lemma he same
is culture much Fossey so now it's a lot
easier for you because you have more
rights and yes and there are ways for
you to denounce any kind of injustice as
far as the rates last week
no employers targeted have been
prosecuted as hundreds of undocumented
workers are detained separated from
their families anytime we execute a
criminal search warrant we're looking
for additional evidence Mike Hurst is a
US attorney for the Southern District of
Mississippi the operation last week was
directed at those who employ
undocumented immigrants yet there are
hundreds of workers in jail and not a
single employer has been prosecuted why
this was simply the execution of
administrative and criminal search
warrants at these different sites if
they come into contact with illegal
aliens their job is to enforce law this
investigation was months in the making
yet Mississippi US Attorney's Office
claims they don't yet have enough
evidence to prosecute any of the
employers responding to the raids cook
food says an employer can
dutifully in Villa gently complying with
the immigration loss and still not know
if someone of its workers or some of its
workers aren't authorized we're talking
about we're talking about hundreds of
workers how can the employer not know in
fact part of the harassment that some of
them are subjected to is that they're
saying if you don't do what we say we're
gonna call immigration also we may not
have to pay you because we're gonna do
go to court you're not a citizen Yeah
right the thing that's so hard maria
aleyne is to see all the children crying
who are separated from their parents so
is there any do you see resolution in
those cases on one hand it's very tough
to see on the other hand people would
say yeah but their parents broke the law
right and that's how that's how it goes
i know we did speak to that to the
daughter of this family to the mother
they said yes we understand but we're
not here to take anything away from
anyone we don't commit any any questions
hurt anyone we just came here to work
and and provide for our children and and
we did talk to the US Attorney about
that and saying does the crime there's a
bunch of these people who are just here
to feed their families and now they're
detained and these employers are not
these are home free what they're family
very quickly are they is the US Attorney
gonna pursue action against the
employers well he says stays in the
middle of the investigation and doesn't
know yet what more do you need to find
out I'm just occasionally you lose your
job then you lose your family and maybe
back wages to write the good thing is
that the family now has permission to go
visit the dad so at least he'll be able
to see thank you so much thank you good
to have you here